and I I started to feel a little bit  uncomfortable  and so I said no I'm sorry yeah bye I've  got to catch a bus and I I turned round  and started to walk very quickly then I  sense real danger because I heard his  footsteps following me and I was heading  for the end of the road  and as I walked faster I could hear his  footsteps getting faster and faster and  then sheer Panic took over  and I started to run towards the end of  the road and as I ran I could feel his  his steps getting nearer and nearer and  nearer so close behind me I had the  hairs on the back of my neck standing up  and my knees went to jelly and then I  felt this massive blow to the top of my  head and I just saw I just saw the  ground coming up towards me and I was  made completely unconscious